wir drehen heute eine neue episode super
easy german wir sind an einer schule im
radio am kopf wie heißt diese schule ist
das buch die medial mich und war im kopf
wie viele schüler gehen zu dieser schule
es gehen 230 schüler zu dieser schule
und welche fremdsprachen lernt man hier
man lernt deutsch und englisch in
englisch ist dreimal in der woche und
deutschland zweimal diese fehler hier
lernen deutsch
deshalb haben wir uns eingeladen ein
video zu drehen
wir gehen jetzt in die schule rein
jetzt sind wir im klassenraum häufig was
ist das
das ist eine kette von deutschlands auf
dieser karte sieht man deutschland es
gibt auf der karte eine legende die
legende erklärt was man auf der karte
sieht
auf dieser karte sieht man sehr schön im
norden von deutschland ist es sehr flach
die grüne fläche in der mitte und im
süden von deutschland gibt es berge
das sind die orangenen flächen pascal
wirkt am lehrerpult pascale warda
das hieß ein computer der computer auf
dem schreibtisch des lehrers der
computer besteht auf dem gehäuse in dem
gehäuse ist der rechner
der computer besteht auch aus einem
bildschirm eine tastatur und eine maus
was ist das das ist eine maus das ist
eine tastatur
das ist der bildschirm mit der maus
klicke ich auf dem bildschirm herum
das ist dennis wenn es was ist das das
ist ein wappen das ist dass waffen von
polen
es besteht aus einem roten hintergrund
und darauf ist ein weißer adler der eine
krone auf hat halo holla was ist das was
ich eintrete
der projektor überträgt das bild von
einem computer auf das whiteboard der
projektor hängt über dem whiteboard
etwas ist dass das ist eine toughe das
ist eine weiße tafel der lehrer schreibt
mit dem stift auf die tafel
ich wische alles wieder weg nicola was
ist das das ist eine wand die banken
geld an dieser wand gibt es noch eine
pinnwand
an der pinnwand gibt es eine stecknadel
mit der stecknadel kann man pro tag an
die pin wand pinnen
hier sehen wir ein poster vom
goethe-institut zum deutsch lernen
zimmern was ist das das ist ein tisch
wir sitzen am tisch jeder schüler in der
klasse hat seinen eigenen tisch das war
unser video aus dem zweiten gymnasium in
radios danke dass du uns eingeladen
heißt lukas litters
[Musik]